we're now on Part C evaluate the
definite integral from zero to ten of H
prime of T DT using correct units
explain the meaning of the expression in
the context of this problem
so we know that if we just want to
evaluate this definite integral from
zero to ten of H prime of T DT this is
just the same thing as evaluating the
antiderivative of this thing right over
here which is just H of T at ten and
subtract from that the antiderivative of
this evaluated at zero this is the
second fundamental theorem of calculus
this is exactly how we evaluate definite
integrals and when you look at it from
this you just see that it's when you
evaluate it it just gives us the
difference in temperature from 0 minutes
to 10 minutes between the temperature of
10 minutes and from that we're taking
this we're subtracting from that the
temperature at 0 minutes so this is
really our change in temperature over
over the first over those over those 10
minutes and we can actually evaluate it
we know what our temperature was after
10 minutes H of 10 is 43 degrees Celsius
so this is 43 right over here and from
that we're going to subtract our initial
temperature our temperature at 0 minutes
which is 66 degrees Celsius we're going
to subtract 66 degrees Celsius this
gives us negative 23 degrees Celsius so
our change in temperature is negative 23
degrees or our temperature has gone down
23 degrees Celsius over the course of
the first 10 minutes so that is part
that is Part C right over there now
let's do Part D Part D D at time T
equals 0 biscuits with temperature
hundred degrees we removed from an oven
so now we're talking about biscuits we
started with T now biscuits the
temperature of the biscuits at time T is
modeled by a differentiable function B
for which it is known that B prime of T
is equal to this business right over
here using the given models at time T
equals 10 how much cooler are the
biscuits than the T well we know what
the temperature of the tea is so we just
have to figure out the temperature of
the biscuits to figure out how much
cooler they are then the T and to figure
out the temperature of the biscuits we
can essentially just use the exact same
idea we can say how much did the we know
that the biscuits started off at 100
degrees
Celsius and we could say well how much
did they cool cool down or what was
their change in temperature over the 10
minutes if we know the change in
temperature and we know it started at
100 degrees then we can use that
information to get what it's temperature
is at 10 minutes and then we can answer
their question so the change in
temperature over those 10 minutes is
just the definite integral from 0 to 10
of this business right over here of let
me just write it so you see it's the
exact same pattern as what we saw over
here this was for the cookies now we're
talking about the biscuits and this
right over here is going to be the
definite integral from 0 to 10 B prime
of T they give it to us right over here
is negative 13 point 8 4 e to the
negative 0.173 T DT and now we just
evaluate this so we can let's take thee
well we can evaluate this what we have
to do is because we know that the
derivative we know the derivative of e
to the ax is a e to the X let me write
that the derivative of e to the ax is
equal to AE to the ax just from the
chain rule derivative the inside is just
a and then we multiply that times the
derivative of the entire thing and
derivative of e to the X is just e to
the X or we could say that the integral
of e to the ax DX is the same is equal
to 1 over a he to the ax plus C and you
could take the derivative of this to see
that you would get this right over here
so using that same idea the
antiderivative of this over here just
going to be the negative thirteen point
eight four and we're going to divide by
this by this coefficient on the tee
right over here so negative zero point
one seven three and you could use your
calculator calculators are allowed for
this part of the problem but we can do
this analytically times e to the
negative zero point one seven three
times t and we're going to evaluate that
we're going to evaluate that from from
zero to ten so we're going to evaluate
it at ten and subtract from that this
thing evaluated at zero so this is going
to be let me just let me just factor out
this part right over here so it's going
to be negative thirteen point eight four
over negative zero point one
seven three times this evaluate a twenty
is 10 so e to the if we multiply this
times ten this is negative one point
seven three that's when I evaluate it at
ten and from that we want to subtract
when this is evaluated zero if the
exponent here is 0 if T is zero the
whole exponent is zero so e to the zero
power is just equal to one and now we
can get our calculator out to evaluate
this so get my t i-85 out and i get i'm
just going to evaluate this inner
expression right over here so e to the e
to the negative one point seven three
and from that from that i want to
subtract i want to subtract one so that
gives me negative 0.8 to two so that's
this part in parenthesis and then i want
to multiply it times what i have out
front so my previous answer times and I
won't write the negative just because
the negative divided by negative is
going to be a positive so it's just
thirteen point eight four divided by
divided by 0.173
because I didn't write the negatives
because they just cancel out and that
gives me negative sixty five point eight
one seven so this is our change in
temperature for the biscuits it's our
change in temperature let me write it
down negative sixty five point eight one
or eight two degrees so this is negative
sixty five point eight two degrees
Celsius this is our change in
temperature this is our change in temp
for the biscuits now we know that they
started off at a hundred degrees and
they went down by 65 point eight two
degrees over the ten minutes so let's
just we they started at one hundred and
then they went down by this previous
amount so whoops I want to subtract the
answer so minus the answer oh sorry I
want to actually add the change in
temperature want to be very careful here
it went down by sixty five degrees so I
really should just say I really should
say one hundred one hundred minus sixty
five point eight one seven yeah I could
keep adding digits if I want to for
seven that's enough
so after ten
the biscuits are 34.1 eight degrees and
we already know we already knew what the
change in temperature for the or what
the temperature of the of the tea is
after 10 minutes we already knew as 43
degrees so the biscuits are at 34
degrees
the tea is at sorry that biscuits are 34
degrees the tea is at 43 degrees so if
we do 43 is where the tea is and we
subtract the temperature of the biscuits
we see that the the biscuits are eight
point eight two degrees cooler eight
point eight two degrees Celsius cooler
so we could say the biscuits the
biscuits are eight point eight two
degrees Celsius cooler than the tea and
we're done with Part D as well